oh wow I was sickened I was sickened by
the standing ovation
I felt like Hollywood is just spineless
on Mass
and uh it just it really felt like oh
this is a really clear indication that
we're not the cool Club anymore
it's Chris do you want to file charges
and Chris apparently said no he did not
he doesn't want the hassle I I had a for
announced this morning that I was suing
will for 200 million dollars because
that video is going to be there forever
it's going to be ubiquitous you do not
have the right to walk up on stage and
smack somebody in the face because they
said words I don't have anything against
Will Smith he's done great things but
that was not a good moment it casts uh
appall over
everybody's Shining Moment